so you are one of not the best like
fraudster
investigators in the world did you sense
did you uh was this on your radar at all
SPF in the over the past couple years
were any red flags going off for you yes
so funny enough like one of my videos
from six months ago or so blew up
because um
I Gotta Give a lot of credit to Matt
Levine of Bloomberg great journalist
great Finance journalist and I want to
say when I like talk about media Elite
there are people doing great work in
these mainstream institutions it's not a
monolith just like Independent Media
isn't all doing great work and all the
corporate media is bad or whatever
there's like these overarching
narratives that I don't subscribe to so
Matt Levine's great journalist he he did
an interview with SPF where he got Sam
to basically describe a lot of what was
going on in D5 but a kind of a larger
philosophy around crypto and he
described a Ponzi scheme where he just
described as Black Box it does nothing
but if we ascribe it value then we can
create more value and more value and
more value and it kind of was this
ridiculous description of a Ponzi scheme
but there was no moral judgment on it it
was like oh yeah this is great we can
make a lot of money from this and Matt
is like well it sounds like you're in
the Ponzi business and business is good
I made a video about that I said this is
ridiculous this is absurd whatever it's
obscene
but
um
I didn't explicitly call SBF a fraud
there
and I think if if I'm being I think I
saw some of it but like many people I
think a lot of us were kind of like
I think a lot of us missed how wrong
everyone could be at the same time
I did notice leading up to the crash
what was happening and I and I caught it
out a day a day or a day and a half
before it happened because I saw my
friends post a dirty bubble media and
this was the first real look into the
heart of their finances because they're
this black box you just kind of had to
evaluate them
without knowing much
and once we got a peek under the hood of
what their finances were
I realized oh my gosh these guys might
be completely insolvent so I made a
tweet about it I hope some people saw it
and got their money out
um
but pretty quickly after that I caught
The Narrative of what was really going
on at Alameda
that it was basically this Ponzi scheme
that they had built do you ever sit like
Batman in The Dark since he fight crime
and wonder like sad just staring into
the darkness and thinking I should have
caught this earlier
yeah I think in your in your uh 10
billion dollars 10 million dollars 10
million dollars we're working our way
there
um sure like it's never enough It's
never enough like you always could be
catching stuff sooner you always could
be doing more I mean the fascinating
thing you said is that
one of the lessons here is that a large
number of people influential smart
people could all be wrong at the same
time in terms of their evaluation of SBF
this is this is one thing that I don't
understand too is like I think it's one
thing to not see something I think it's
another thing to like rubber stamp or
explicitly endorse I feel like
a lot of people didn't look too close at
SPF because I think a lot of the warning
signs were there but my feeling is if
you're a sequoia if you're a black rock
wouldn't you do that due diligence I
mean like yeah like before just
endorsing something especially in the
crypto space this is just why I don't do
any deals in the crypto space ever
because it's impossible to know which
ones are going to be the like big hits
or the big frauds or you know whatever
um but if you're gonna make that bet if
you're going to make that play you would
think
that you would do all the research in
the world and you would get
sophisticated looks at their liabilities
at how they were structured all that
stuff and that is the most shocking part
is not that you know people missed it
because you can miss fraud but that
there were so much so many glowing
endorsements like this guy is not going
to be that thing we explicitly endorse
him I saw a Fortune Magazine he was
called the next Warren Buffett it's just
crazy do you think it's possible to have
enough like Tom Brady
uh endorsements that you don't really
investigate so like yes that there's a
kind of momentum like societal so it's
momentum I think that's the problem I
actually think that's hugely a blind
like a a blind spot of our society as we
have all these heuristics that can be
points of failure where like a rule of
thumb is if you go to an Ivy League well
you must be smart right a rule of thumb
is if you're both your parents are
Harvard lawyers you must not you must
know the law you must like kind of be
sophisticated the rule of thumb is if
you're running a billion dollar exchange
you must be somehow somewhat ethical
right and all of these heuristics can
lead to Giant blind spots where you kind
of just go oh we'll check like I don't
really it's a lot of energy to look into
people and if enough of those rules of
thumb are met we just kind of check them
off and put them through the system so
uh yeah it's been hugely exposing for
sort of like our blind spot and you
don't know maybe how to look in for
example there's a few assumptions now
there's a lot of people are very
skeptical of institutions of government
and so on but for um perhaps too much so
I agree but for some part of history
there was a too much faith in government
yeah and so
um right now I think there's faith in
certain large companies there's distrust
in certain ones and Trust in others like
people seem to distrust Facebook
extremely skeptical Facebook but they
trust I think Google with their data I
think they trust apple with their data
sure much much more so like search
people don't seem to be a Google search
like I'm just gonna I'm gonna throw it
in there have you ever looked at your
Google search history your Google search
history has got to be the some of the
darkest things oh I don't think I've
ever looked at my Google search history
you should be careful with uh like
browser hygiene and uh stuff like that
because I think it's
well Google search history unless you
explicitly delete is there I recommend
you look at it it's fascinating look
because it goes back to the first days
of you using Google search history fun
fact actually about that no no I I I am
I am aware of that
um I just mean for like certain
sensitive topics where like I'm
investigating some fraud and I go sign
into their website right log in I won't
use like a traditional browser I'll use
a VPN and I'll like put it on like Brave
or something like that you log in you
create an account as Lex Friedman yeah
exactly exactly